queridos compatriotas
del continente de ultramar y franceses
del mundo el pueblo francés se ha
expresado
el honor de calificar para la segunda
vuelta frente al presidente saliente
[Aplausos]
se le permita expresarle a todos los
millones de electores de atracción que
me expresaron su confianza todo mi
agradecimiento lo pido con humildad
asumo con edad todas las
responsabilidades los veo en la
esperanza la esperanza que te
representan las fuerzas de recuperación
de este país en esta primera vuelta
harvey
32 visiones opuestas del ifai el futuro
en este país la justicia y el desorden
de impuestos por emanuel bach o en
beneficio de algunos pocos o la reunión
de los franceses en torno a la justicia
social y la protección garantizados por
un marco fraterno en torno de la idea
milenaria de las naciones y los pueblos
todos los que hoy no votaron por emanuel
mayor tienen vocación de reunirse para
hacer
agrupación
me alegro de que este debate sea
esencial quiero que sea leal y
respetuoso durante estos 15 días que
quedan para que el pueblo soberano
francés pueda arbitrar lo con su voto el
24 de abril próximo en esta campaña
decidí ser libre de las ataduras de
partido para poderme dirigir
directamente a ustedes seguiré
haciéndolo
si ustedes lo quieren al día siguiente
del segundo de la segunda vuelta como
presidenta de todos los franceses
[Aplausos]
y este 24 de abril no es solamente un
voto de circunstancias sino una decisión
de sociedad e incluso de civilización de
su voto depende en todo el territorio
francés
la preponderancia legítima de la cultura
y de la lengua francesa de los usos y
costumbres en nuestra región y de los
medios de vida de los franceses de las
leyes y valores republicanos
en primer lugar la laicidad posible
igualdad especialmente entre hombres y
mujeres de su voto depende también el
lugar que en nuestra sociedad queremos
darle a las personas frente al poder del
dinero pienso por ejemplo en la
importancia que le otorgamos a la
solidaridad hacia las más vulnerables la
posibilidad de disfrutar de derechos
garantizados o incluso de acceder a la
jubilación en buena salud da su voto del
24 de abril dependerán finalmente a las
decisiones políticas del próximo
quinquenio pero que en realidad van a
comprometer a francia por los 50
próximos años la política migratoria de
seguridad económica social energética
europea militar o diplomática
mi compromiso sobre estos temas no
tienen fallas asumiré la independencia
nacional para hacer de francia una
potencia de avance restaurar en todos
los campos la soberanía de francia es
decir para los franceses la libertad de
decidir por sí mismos de defender sus
intereses
y mirar a la inmigración y restablecer
la seguridad para todos mediante la
escucha y la atención garantizar el
respeto de cada uno de ustedes y
especialmente a los simples ciudadanos
los funcionarios y todos los
representantes políticos que han sido
temas serían respetados durante este
último energía
asumida en los retos del país y las
soluciones que les propongo en intento
el marco de un proyecto equilibrado
trabajado y cifrado con esta seriedad
espero rectos componer las múltiples
fracturas en una francia muy
dañada
la fractura social territorial
institución y cultural médica digital
volveré a poner a francia en orden en
estos cinco años para darle un lugar
eminente en este siglo 21 lleno de
promesas y de oportunidades puesto que
más allá de esta recuperación necesaria
mi proyecto tiene grandes ambiciones
para el país una ambición democrática
con el referéndum de iniciativa
ciudadano con una proporcional para
permitir que todas las opiniones
políticas se expresen
y que estén representadas en la asamblea
nacional es una ambición económica y
ecológica
[Aplausos]
una ambición económica y ecológica que
apoya los regresos de la prosperidad y
el pleno empleo el
patriotismo
y el apoyo a las pequeñas y medianas
empresas que crean empleo reveló
revitalizar el espíritu de empresa y
reconciliar el trabajo y el capital
unión que la participación una ambición
social que le garantice a todos una
escuela del saber la promoción social y
la asimilación del poder adquisitivo los
salarios y pensiones dignos
educación de calidad accesible a todos y
para todos una vivienda decente en
nuestro país debe enorgullecerse de no
abandonar a ninguno de sus niños
asegurar la el reconocimiento de la
meditó y abrirle a cada uno las piernas
de la felicidad familiar y la
realización personal es una misión
soberana por último para restaurar el
estado fortalecer sus medios y su
autoridad teniendo cuidado de netapp o
la moralidad de sus agentes las
necesidades morales garantizar las
libertades de todos es un estado
estratega piso de la nación un estado
que está bien
misión principal es unir a los franceses
en torno a este gran proyecto nacional y
popular
participación a los jóvenes un poder
federador para volver a hacer de nuestra
nación una comunidad de destinos unidos
o sea una nación y por encima francia un
país es jefe han se reanuda con la
prosperidad y la grandeza llamo a todos
los franceses con todas en silla de
derecha de izquierda y otras bases es de
todos los orígenes los llamo a reunirse
senté en esta gran agrupación nacional
juntos vamos a construir con entusiasmo
y condiciones está victoria para poner
en práctica esta gran alternancia que
francia necesita y para llevar adelante
con felicidad a nuestro país al tercer
milenio
viva la república viva
[Aplausos]